them the common points are often true
and and now you know if you do
scholarship Martin Gilbert the Churchill
biographer was a teacher of mine used to
tell me used to say he wouldn't let if
you if you use the word perhaps he would
circle it and put perhaps not and and he
would say in the study of 19th and 20th
century history there isn't really any
room for the word perhaps you can look
it up and you know there's a guy in the
press lately I can't remember his name
and it's probably good that I can't
he's a galvanizing popular population
politician in the state of India and
he's been going around giving speeches
about how Winston Churchill is like
Hitler and he is they were both human
beings although Hitler almost fell below
the standard of being called that but
one of the things when Sen Churchill did
was starve three million people in the
Indian state of Bengal in the middle of
the Second World War he says that's a
common charge but you know you can go
look that up we're publishing the
document volume it's the official
biography of Churchill and there's just
a lot in there about that because they
are starving there and you know it turns
out they got much of their grain from
the rice bowl
Thailand Vietnam and the Japanese had
conquered that my wife's daddy was a
camp commander of a Japanese powa up for
three years that he was taken during the
course of that conquest so just go look
that up right that's a really important
fact cuz why didn't they have anything
to eat
well the answer is the enemy had the
food and wouldn't give it to them and
you know Churchill might have been fault
in this way or that although he made
serious efforts to get more grain to
India in the middle of a war where
transport was scarce and on the other
hand you know it's like did Churchill
will do enough to save the Jews
well you got to start with the fact that
Hitler killed him and and you know
Churchill killed Hitler so good move
Churchill anyway
I admired that talk very much and you
know in this day and age one of the most
important things we can do in such a
divided time is we can become critical
thinkers we should when you read the
news you should read it I confess I
don't watch the news I made a note to
myself to do a Google Alert for sharyl
Attkisson
because there'll be lots of writing
about what she says on TV and I'm
extremely unlikely to watch the CBS
Evening News but I'll get to see what
she says and that'll be happy for me and
you can do that too and everybody you
respect and then if there's somebody you
really don't respect read them too
because it'll make you mad and give your
day more liveliness
so I have to talk about so we're in the
academic world right and so my topic
assigned to me is conservative and
conservatism and American greatness in a
conference on what is American greatness
what is that's a Socrates question
TSD is the Greek what is the thing
what's a know what it is fundamentally
what it is in its essence and in the
academic world it's always better to
begin fundamentally fundamental is a
fundamental word its cognate with the
word foundation
it means the things at the base so I
don't know you were some you were the
first timers breakfast and it was
absolutely delightful because the idea
was inspired in me of asking Brigitte
and to come up there and she said give a
good talk I'm on the way and she's a
student in my class right now in the
college scene a junior she's a junior
and I said no you give it and so she did
and you know she was awesome right but
then I tortured her best I could and a
young man that I also called up and I
asked him what things mean and that's
hard right what is it good that's the
fundamental question the TSD question
that Socrates asked the most is tht St
Agatha what is the good it's hard to say
what that is but important to say so
I've got three words and it'll get a
little complicated defining them so I'm
gonna talk about a movie that'll help
the three words are greatness America
and conservatism what are those words
mean so greatness I'll start with that
and I'll start with that in part because
this morning a man who just asked a
question where is that guy wanted you to
know the relationship between good and
great oh there you go cuz the famous
book by Jim Collins it's an excellent
book called good to great
we read it around the college it's a
it's one of those splendid pieces of
common sense and it's a big rage in the
business world which is a sign of health
in the Republic and so he developed a
doubt because of our talking about the
good whether there's any difference
between the good and the great so first
of all what is good you know you have to
be able to say and we talked about that
a lot so I'll just repeat it quickly
this morning and if you're not here for
the first time you won't understand but
so what is the horse how do you tell the
difference between a horse and a Great
Dane right a pony and a great day right
huh how do you know and look at us we're
all people and yet we all look different
and so how do you know that we are what
we seem to be what is it about us that
we notice right I have yeah I never have
in it in a room like this so many things
are exactly like other things that it's
hard to do so the people are the best
thing right you got woman and woman
right and if patricia and nina was the
woman this lady next to her whose name i
don't know would not be a woman so
there's something in common that they
have that makes them that that's why we
can use common noun which is exactly the
essence of human rationality it's what
we do is why we can talk thinking and
talking about the same thing and we
think and talk in common nouns
fundamentally proper nouns only makes
sense because they are instances of a
common noun and so that's a bottle and
if you cut the bottom and it's a good
one it works right looks upside down
it's not leaking I can get the top off
reasonably easy it'll be good to drink
from because it's narrow up here at the
top and I won't slobber all over myself
right if you cut the bottom off it won't
be any good anymore
you can carry it like this but every
time you said it don't it fall over
that's such a good one
but if you take the top off then what it
would be really good for would being
funnel as it loses the good of the
bottle it either becomes nothing or it
gains the being and good of something
else and so the philosopher says the
good and being are convertible terms and
if you want to think about this which is
I've thought about is you might be able
to tell for many years now I just enjoy
that question to death and and and I
make the students suffer but just think
about that when you want to know what
good is and you want to know what being
is remember that they're synonyms and
construct a sentence and put one in and
then put the other in and you'll see
that it works right that's good what's
great-great comes from an old word that
means bigger thicker coarser larger
right and it forever meant that but if
you look in edit my logical etymological
dictionaries I don't know if you do that
or not but there's there's one that's
free called the online etymological
dictionary and I read a story about the
guy who does it he's a cranky old guy
and he's just giving his life to this
and it's a great service because what it
is is the history of words what words do
they come from and how do they develop
the great source for that is of course
the Oxford English Dictionary but you
can also look up on the internet I think
you have to pay but I'm not sure the
online etymological dictionary tends to
be the first result if you just put in
etymology good that's what will come up
is the first result on Google I do it
all the time well great and it also
tells you how the word it's a Dutch
German Northern Europe word right it's
not a romantic word it's not from Latin
or Greek
it's from northern Europe but then this
online etymological dictionary tells us
that in 1848 the first Jews that can be
found of it to mean excellent not just
large excellent
more of the good the good elevated the
good intensified there's a phenomenon in
classical philosophy that there's a word
that's sort of above the word good in a
Kalon or Kalos is the word and it
translates one good way to translate it
as beautiful noble is also a good way to
translate it and the beautiful or the
Noble that's not just good that's better
best even see
and so greatness of America would be if
America was a good kind of thing and if
it was excellent
or the most excellent at being that kind
of thing so that's what those words mean
I think and that set you out thinking
now because to no I just said the good
of a thing you have to know the being of
a thing and that means you can't talk
about American greatness until you
identify what America is and come to
find out in this controversial time the
source of the deep controversies is a
difference about what America is and
there are two stories to tell I'll try
to tell them as stories cuz they'll be
easier to understand how many people
have seen the movie 2001 a lot I'll tell
you a little bit about it but I urge you
to go watch it because although it's
what is it like it's weighty and vague
and compelling you know but there's a
story in it and it actually is the view
of the world from the point of view of
modern liberalism at the beginning of
the story there's some Apes and they're
grunting and fighting with the ape tribe
next door and
fighting with a panther who eats one of
them and it's a lot of grunting and a
lot of you know it's kind of savage
start looking and then they get up one
morning and there's this monolith and
you know there isn't anything in nature
that's got perfect animal angles and
smooth sides and this model is perfectly
shaped and simply undistinguished was
black and a perfectly smooth surface it
just doesn't look like it goes there at
all it has to be artificial I just say
made by some purpose not natural because
Nature doesn't at least in our world
produce things like that and this thing
streaks at them this monolith and the
next thing you know one of the Apes
picks up a stick and hits the panther
with it now the ape can pick up the
stick because the ape has an opposable
thumb and in the liberal or modern
understanding of human being that's
really crucial because we human beings
are tool users and makers we use
implements and weapons and and and we
and and and so he picks up this dick and
he kills the Panther one um and then
they have a fight with the tribe next
door and they just kick the crap out of
them because now they're wave and he
sticks around hitting people with them
and then in the last stage before it
cuts away to something I'll tell you
about in the last stage there's a whole
flurry of animals getting whacked in the
head and fallen over dead these Apes are
eating really well now and that's not
good for the other animals
it changes nature and it changes the
Apes nature is changed in the modern
liberal understanding in the last scene
about the Apes one of the Apes throws
the stick way up in the air and it goes
up like that and then the picture
resolved it's it's a very good movie by
the way it's very well shot although
it's kind of hard to figure out
especially at the end what the devil it
means but uh but then the
next thing you know there's a modern
woman and she turns out to be a
stewardess on the spaceship and she's
walking around in zero gravity and she's
beautiful and she's not like the Apes
she's erect and she's surveying a guy
who's ballpoint pen floats off in the
air right so we've cut from the monolith
changing the ape and it's using tools to
the next stage and the next stage is us
and we look different right our physical
appearance has evolved significantly
we're still bipeds and we're still
upright
and because we're upright vision is
still our chief sense but you can just
see they're thinking once you start
using these clubs the next thing you
know you're going to the moon it stops
in the middle and I'll interject this
now because it's really good as a
picture of modern government they
stopped at the Internet some space
station and they changed
spaceships I guess and and a bunch of
international bureaucrats sit around and
talk and they talk just like bureaucrats
talk it's all very civil and polite and
they're asking each other questions and
nobody's given anybody any information
and it's all very civil and it's all
very obscure and then they get up to the
moon and come to find out up on the moon
they've discovered this another monolith
up there and I'll cut to the chase the
point is apparently these alien beings
who make these monoliths they planted
one to get us started on the earth and
they planted one up on the moon for us
eventually to uncover and when it gets
uncovered it sends a signal to Jupiter
where these beings apparently are
located and that tells us them we're
here and we've got this far and now it's
time for us to make contact and if you
just think about that story for a minute
it means that it's a story of evolution
of change and they're gonna meet a
different kind of being you don't ever
really get to see that kind of being it
seems to have power this other kind of
being on Jupiter it's in later books in
this series it's it's emerged that this
other being is strong enough using these
monoliths to create other moons and
maybe planets and it's also strong
enough to age us and then reverse our
age because one of the astronauts
becomes a very old man and then it
becomes in the last seeing a little baby
floating up in the heaven somehow so
it's a story of change and the story of
change involves us using tools to affect
the change and change ourselves in
nature and in addition it's a story of
science which comes from the Latin word
to know what doesn't really mean knowing
any more now it means sophisticated use
of tools to affect change these tools
are invented by what we call the
scientific method which is you just
control everything said it's a chain of
a Vincent in motion observe what happens
see if it confirms what you'd speculated
at the beginning and then do it over and
over again and that's the only way to
learn but if you learn you can grow very
great power and of course it is a fact
that that works and it is a fact that
that is remaking the world all the time
this faked knows stuff right what that
used to be like a hundred years ago was
they used to be at least two newspapers
in every town and at least two of them
would be affiliated with a political
party and carry that in its title so it
was easy to figure out you know which
one you'd like the better and also it's
easy to figure out how to read them both
and make sure you get both arguments
right but today it's coming from
everywhere and incredible rights all day
just you know I know and you
we don't that speaker Ryan has announced
he's not gonna seek reelection this year
and that probably happened 15 minutes
ago and I found it out probably two
minutes after that right well it just
changes everything if the pace and the
quantity are so different and I said at
the beginning that this scholarship is
actually how you sort this stuff out but
Lord there's a lot to sort out now and
that means that you are required more
than you used to be required to make
priorities and figure out what's
important and focus on understanding
that because you can't understand
everything anymore can't follow
everything anymore this new
understanding of America what's great
about America what America is it's the
greatest country in the world
many American liberals think that I mean
they also very impatient was it -
because it's hidebound in certain ways
but right there in the beginning the
principle of change was the key
principle it was open to radical
development and it could become whatever
it wanted to become the argument for the
living Constitution you know by the way
I believe in the living Constitution I
believe it's still the law in the land
but the living Constitution meaning
whatever the devil we want it to mean
today that is the explicit basis of that
expression in many famous Supreme Court
opinions right it just means what we see
it to mean today given all of our
conditions everything changes see and
the greatness of America is that now if
you think about that one step more and
think about that moving the difference
between the ape and that woman that you
see next is a very big difference and
the implication is the next difference
you see will be a very big difference -
and that means the ape and the woman
have something in common
they're both weigh stations on a journey
they're changing
the process of change is sovereign our
dignity such as we have it is that we
can maybe get control of the process but
that means you could do just about
anything to that woman just like was
done with that ape that's one view of
American and its greatness the other
view is different in kind it's not
different in degree it's a different
kind it's a different principle it's a
different beginning point in way of
thinking modern liberalism doesn't
really start with nature it starts with
change and converts nature into change
the American Revolution and classical
thought at this level of abstraction is
the same they start with nature and what
does nature mean it's a very pregnant
word it's a great word it means it's it
starts out meaning birth it's a Latin
word for birth or it means more
generally the process of beginning and
growth by which living things come to be
so plantain acorn oak tree comes plant a
pine nut cone pine tree comes and and
that and you know two people get married
I mean formerly of the different genders
then
you know you they're gonna make human
children if they make any children at
all and that's nature right and think
about it yeah it says so much as implied
in that word because if it means
beginning and growth growth is a
troublesome term because our children
you know like Bridget this morning she
just was spectacular this morning and I
was very impressed I expected to be I
ever in class right now but but more
than I expected right because she's
grown up right and that means at that
kind of things she did this morning
bridget is better at that than she would
have been five years ago and you know
didn't you think about this not as good
as she will be in five years she's still
growing but you know living things all
end up the same way dead and also
declining and so to define growth is a
little bit complicated because how do
you know when it stops growing and it
starts to King you know compare Bridget
with me and it leaked physically
physically she's on the way up I'm not
right now how do you know that because
you know Bridget didn't I by the way are
going to end up in exactly the same
condition indeed exactly the same
condition is the oak tree we're gonna
rot you know so when does the growth
stop and the decay begin and the answer
is it's probable that I at least and all
of you in your essential human
characteristics are still growing and
the time is likely to come if you live a
very long time when that will stop when
you become physically weak in ways that
prevent you from growing but if you can
teach a class and argue with the young
and come to this conference we're still
growing
but what that growing means is that in
those respects although not physically
physically we are becoming more fully
like ourselves we are becoming better
human beings what Marc Anthony says
Brutus not long before he killed him he
was the noblest Roman of them all he was
sanguine and the elements were all were
so mixed up in him then all nature could
complain it could proclaim this was a
man right fully a man having all the
elements of the man that requires being
mature and mature not just in body but
in character and and in other words he's
calling Brutus a great man he can't be a
great man unless you're grown you have
to be big enough to be a man fully a man
but that's not decisive the decisive
things are the development all of the
qualities that amount to excellence and
that's a contained in that idea of that
little seed and that growth and then if
you think beyond that just one more step
you find out that there's lots and lots
of things that have natures that grow
and each of those things is different
and so nature comes to mean
Yosemite Valley right the arrangement of
all of the living things and then
because the whole cosmos moves in a
pattern nature means the whole order and
way of nature I think what a word that
is and if you put in the Declaration of
Independence the laws of nature and of
nature's God
that's a whack in big statement right
and think how they deploy those words
they they are saying to the King of
England who is the most powerful human
being on earth and they don't even have
an army well they do have an army it's a
pitiful little thing and they've
appointed George Washington to head it
and he had never in turned out to be one
of the greatest people who ever live but
you couldn't tell that for sure at that
time what you didn't know is that
neither he nor anybody else who's on the
side of Independence
had ever moved a large army from one
place to another and that was one of
George Washington's very early failings
right that he at the Battle of New York
right he just couldn't get his army he
could he didn't actually couldn't figure
out very well where it should go he got
better at that but having figured out
where to go he didn't know how to get it
there and all these British generals
they just grew up on that stuff right
and they just were just adapt and
tremendous and just overwhelmed him for
most of the American Revolutionary War
so in it a crazy thing for them to write
this thing to the king up ending all he
understood to be his authority and they
needed something big to do that and the
big thing was the laws of nature and of
nature's God and they are grounded in
this idea of the good that we have right
because they're saying to him in the
declaration is what does human equality
mean right it can't mean we're all the
same size it can't mean we're all the
same smarts it can't mean we're all the
same sex can't mean we're all the same
industry everybody knows that nobody's
ever really been seriously confused
about that it means that we're all the
same kind of thing and that includes the
king and so when you King want to rule
any other person and it doesn't matter
if your family is old and you ride in a
golden carriage and the armies respond
to you what it means is you can't do
anything to us without our permission
that's nature and you see how
differently that regards us right it
means that cus it and stubborn and awful
as we are we may not be governed without
our consent
however willful we may be at our animal
nature to want things it is wrong for us
to take something that right that
belongs to another person
the the idea of equality that's common
to that other view is that since
everything is changing including us and
since we are going to use science and
sophisticated tools to control that
process we can actually have a goal to
make a quality mean we all come out the
same but of course that has to be
engineered which is the purpose of
higher modern education and also why
schools are so boring
because it's a stupid undertaking and
when you get in the middle of it nobody
likes it especially young people who
don't know any better
old people can see it is a way to
manipulate an engineer upon another
person's which is how the schools are
organized today it's the reason most of
its employees don't teach most of its
employees it's hard to tell what they
most of them do because it's very artful
you know we have this wonderful
transparent and accountable government
and I guess Frank Luntz is teaching me
to use the word accountable now not
transparent and transparent that's an
old word - so he but but they don't keep
the data so that you can know sorry I
shut it up so that you can know what all
the people do they're just grouped into
huge category other and you know that's
half the staff of the public schools and
you just it's very difficult to find out
what they're actually doing but you do
know that a significant number of them
are in the business of telling teachers
what to do so they can tell students
what to do so this old idea of equality
stops all this and this old idea has two
characteristics that I have to mention
and one of them is it's incredibly
stubborn you can watch the movie 2001
all you want to but if they took out
that woman that handsome woman who is
serving on the space ship and they did
something cruel to her everybody would
think that was wrong or in our
Constitution reader because we tried
teach people to be scholars which is
careful thinkers we had we we produced
the Alabama slave code it's a really
great document to read right and what it
does is it its rules about the slaves
and about all the free white males have
to ride Posse once a month looking for
runaways because as we know from the
doctrines of the Confederacy slavery was
very popular among the slaves
except for this embarrassing fact that
they kept trying to get away and but the
rules are like this slave can't be off
the plantation without written
permission for more than three hours I
think it is you can't have a slave in
dwelling not on the plantation without
written permission for more than thirty
minutes
slaves can't gather in groups larger of
three for more than thirty minutes
without the master or his representative
present right
just think what kind of life that is
living under rules like that right
you can't like four of you show up well
you got to look around and see if you've
been there too long but then in that
Alabama slave code and I'm telling you
it's just an organized system for
treating people like animals there's an
exemption to these gathering rules and
that's an exemption when the slaves are
meeting with the preacher in that
interesting now there are laws in in
countryside in America today and were
then about how you have to fence your
animals in or else they'll get out and
eat somebody else's stuff or getting
away the road right those laws about
those animals don't include any
exemptions about unless the animals
happen to be going to church
or as Lincoln said famously one time
Douglass says he can take his hog on his
blackboard in Nebraska and the federal
government protect his property in it
why can't he take his slave and Lincoln
said good question if there's a
difference between the hog and the slave
but down south they don't pass laws
making it illegal to teach hogs to read
we see things and we have this gift we
recognize what they are and it's very
stubborn it's hard to drive it away in
the von C conference where the Nazis had
a big conference and planned the final
solution factories to put people on
cattle cars and take them by railroad to
a factory to kill them in mass and they
did kill several million that way they
took careful notes and they let
everybody take up one set of notes to
study for months with a promise to
destroy them and they kept records of
everybody who got him made him sign a
book but why destroyed the notes right
they were embarrassed these are not in
fact cattle these are people stubborn
right and the second thing about America
in its original meaning because this
liberal understanding of the beginning
of America that what's distinctive about
it is that it's open is of course an
obvious and willful misreading of the
American Revolution
partly the misreading was done out of
charity they wanted to admire it
but they had to take out that part about
you can never rule me except by my
consent
that's a fixity right and then because
we're animals too we're going to require
to have rules but those but the people
who live under those rules they're
animals just like us they can't have
absolute power they're constrained first
by consent but also by representation
and separation of powers and all that
stuff and that to say Woodrow Wilson for
example that just gets in
way of the scientific enterprise that's
written like the world was still
understood in terms of Newton he writes
this explicitly you know as far as I
know I see it earlier back there he
probably know better than I do but they
I don't know that Newton never comes up
but now we have Darwin he says
everything changes see so the old way is
stubborn but also the old way pushes
tremendous energy right why do you work
you got to eat
do you work better when you get to build
something and keep it you see the energy
and hope that comes from the principle
of equality and the understanding of
nature that are the correct ones and the
undeniable one by the witness of our own
eyes they have remade the world they
have actually the thing that did that if
you just studied the story of America it
is unique it is obviously one of the
greatest and best things that ever
happened because it starts from nothing
set along the Seaboard getting these big
pretensions about being government
governed by their consent and we've
settled the continent and spread free
and representative government across the
continent step by step and without any
interruption and we have the stain of
slavery every human society we have
other stains too plenty of them but
every human society has stains the
stains are trouble us because in our
Constitution reader John Wright John Jay
writes a great letter to a head of the
English manumission that freed the
slaves society and he says you know
what's going on over here he says we
there's always been slavery around and
nobody thought about it very much you
know North and South it was - but he
said under the influence of this thing
we have done
we are waking up and we are starting to
get rid of that and I expect that
process to go on I'll tell you what
interrupted it by the way is the first
American version of this progressive
history the first American version of
the progressive Harriet history was in
the Confederacy and it was on the right
the modern ones are on the left you see
but just think what it how it liberates
you know you know what our College is so
good I mean it is really good come and
see it but I I'll tell you why it's so
good you know I'd like to tell you it's
my personal brilliant they come to find
out and it is no but come to find out
it's because we all do it right every
day everybody's working on it you know
many of us have bad days pretty often
right but everybody is after the same
thing because we agreed to be and you
know you want to get in Hillsdale
College go make a perfect score on the
SCT and then come and fit in the
admissions office and tell them that
you're not sure you want to come see if
you get in right whereas somebody who
makes 80th percentile and I think our
numbers run in the mid-90s now and they
just come in and they just say you're
good somebody I had woman said this to
me with Jeff Lantis who's here the
former admissions director now his
athletic stuff he's an old jock this
this girl said to me I'd known her since
she was little and she didn't have a
very good academic record and she said
you look in my office demanded to get in
my office and she said you are gonna let
me in here
and I did you know so do you see we have
a fight between two things that are
incompatible and they regard us in an
entirely different light right and the
indignity of the intellectual classes in
America at the rudeness of the mid the
Midwest and the south and the rural
areas their displeasure at the current
president United States because of his
rudeness and clumsiness and
unwillingness to play the game right and
you know he does seem to be looser with
women than him fella ought to be you
know and I don't like that right but you
kind of got to admire his enemies for
him for his enemies right and he doesn't
seem to be afraid of them and they and
and and the point is I think their
indignation is real and heartfelt
because they believe in this vision that
we can remake everything right and to
sort that is to thwart the highest duty
wears people like me and you probably
what I think is the most beautiful thing
that ever happened in politics is the
American Declaration of Independence and
the career of the people who wrote them
and the fact that it produces people
like us and what are we except ordinary
people who get a chance to live a great
and fully human life
that means this is a conflict of
principle and it means it's not gonna go
away it has to be decided one way or
t'other and I'll just say one thing
about conservatism because I guess I
supposed to talk about that but I don't
know conservatism at its best means the
love of that strain that produced the
United States of America which reaches
by the way back through the great books
and the great civilizations it's divided
conservatism it's got more than one
strain of thought in it practical
situations like the current political
situation tend to divide the
Conservatives but just think about
conservatism if you have a conservative
disposition it means you kind of like to
preserve things but you know the past is
like the present there's a lot uglier
there you know you know what they say is
the oldest profession right I don't
actually think that's true I think the
oldest profession is farming but
but that other profession has a certain
notoriety right and you wouldn't want to
conserve that well some people would I
guess but um so we're living here it's
not just true that the greatness of
America is at stake there are
alternative views of what that greatness
constitutes and they can't both be right
one of them has got to derive from the
real goodness of America its actual
identity and only that one could be
great and so I would suggest that we
organize our lives to try to perpetuate
that thank you
look at the question flow okay we have
time for questions again please wait for
the microphone they may be moving a
little slowly because we're as I said a
little cozy in here but be patient and
the microphone will be brought to you so
questions please
Jef Myers from Summit ministries can you
expand a little bit on the comment you
made about progressive action in the
1800's interrupting the movement against
slavery can you expand on that so you
know John C Calhoun was you can't
understand Lincoln that's like mr.
Atkinson point right you can't
understand Lincoln if you don't read
Stephen Douglas and John Cale Calhoun
right because and John Calvin's a little
tedious but he was a graduate from Yale
University and he was a student of
Friedrich Hegel he fancied himself an
Aristotelian but I have arguments why I
don't think that works and he's the one
most prominently in early declare
slavery a good thing and why is it good
because they're in a different condition
than we are their humanity is not the
decisive thing if they've got it they're
a different kind of thing and it would
be an abomination to live with them as
equal citizens and because we are
superior to them we all become
aristocrats and then there can be
harmony in the society you see and that
is many other people not so much Calhoun
but say Alexander Stephens the vice
presidency vice president of the
Confederacy they ascribe these
differences to evolution a development
of change right Calhoun is a kind of
scientific utopian he brought this book
called the disquisition on government
and it's I once I'm so proud of myself
about this and the college I once messed
up my syllabus and you know we read the
great documents from American history in
our introductory politics course on the
Constitution the United States we start
with Aristotle and we read through you
know and that means you're reading a lot
of the great documents well the whole
book is 800 pages long I think and the
discus is just disquisition on
government is about that long and I
messed up my syllabus and I I assigned
the reading of it all
and they did and I was at first I was
horrified and I told him and then you
know they were horrified and I said well
well done good job yeah but there's a
line in it it would be this is an exact
quote I think it would be impious let's
say failure of respect toward God to
believe that God would give us the
powers of natural science and permit us
to use them for evil so you see whatever
exercise of human power there is that's
okay that that's the exercise is what
makes it right and that means you know
using an atomic bomb on the village in
northern England where my wife grew up
that would be you know I guess that
would be okay so that's the point and
that comes in through German historicism
and you know human civilization is an
old story and there are many
controversies amidst them and if you
read that story and try to learn about
it first of all it's a lifelong task and
you'll never get it done but a second
thing is it makes your opinions more
moderate because you know what's good
about America
well one huge thing about it is we leave
each other the devil alone right and we
should do that you know I don't like the
way all kinds of people live in America
and I would rather not have to do with
them and if I try to dictate how they
live I'll end up having to do with them
and that would be bad
and I also don't want them trying to
dictate to me that's the kind of
moderate solution to the problem of
politics and when we get these utopian
things politics become extreme like
controlling everything that's said in
the news what kind of what what is that
consent åkesson just described is an
attempt to control what people say do
you know why Winston Churchill knew
Hitler was weak
and could be beaten they might not be
beaten but in principle he could to be
bitten he says what are they afraid of
words they cower right
Churchill was really good with words
that's why he was able to beat him dr.
Arnn I am I have a big belief that God
was involved in the creation of two
countries in this world first one was
Israel well he gave Israel to the Jews
his chosen people and the second one was
bringing together some of the greatest
minds gathered in one room to create
America like your thoughts on that
yeah I think God was heavily involved in
both those things and a bunch of other
stuff too I think I think he's a very
meddlesome God but but I think he
blessed those two things in particular
but you know there think of think of the
bursts of philosophy in Athens and that
was a great thing think of Elizabethan
England Shakespeare right Elizabeth the
first the advance of limited government
that was made possible by this little
country that just by accident had two
features it was cut off by sea from
everybody else and therefore it it and
then that gave rise to the second
feature because it didn't need a big
land army the king was weaker and so the
House of Commons kept winning arguments
with the king over 400 years and cutting
off his head sometimes and then the
second thing was they got really good at
the sea because they're all surrounded
by the sea and the Seas there are very
stormy to use the topical phrase today
and and and so they were great sailors
right and that meant once you get out on
the sea you can go anywhere and so that
spread all over the place sea so I see
the hand of Providence in more things
than just those two but surely those two
we have time for one more question
hi Jeremy I'm Alison from Denver I
recently saw the movie the darkest hour
which I understand you helped to consult
on and it's open I could hear you talk a
little bit about the the movie itself
I've heard a lot of good feedback of the
movie but I specifically heard some
people criticize it because they say
that if portrayed Churchill is being too
weak and I would hope when he could
speak to that specifically in your
remarks yeah you seen the movie well I
loved the movie and I a weird feature of
my life is that I have known Gary Oldman
for a few years and I've known his
producer and manager of his career for
30 years and I like them both a lot and
they set out to make a very great movie
it's a it's a one of the greatest
dramatic demonstrations of the
importance of human choice ever put
together and the reason is that event
that it depicts see what was Hitler's
claim Hitler's claim was just like John
Calhoun's claim just like Joe Stalin's
claim history is on our side and it's
irresistible and we're gonna found the
Thursday dirt thousand-year Reich right
you know it lasted 12 years but you know
he's optimistic he was but he thought it
was irresistible and you know he nearly
won and the reason England didn't get
out of the war is because on the 28th of
May 1940 Winston Churchill walked in a
room and gave one of the greatest
speeches anybody ever gave hard to think
anybody else could have given that
speech it's known that there wasn't
anybody else in the room who wanted to
and he talked him out of it and that's
what that film is about now it's a fact
that the screenwriter and my mad good
guy you know right young man I'm old now
so I think of everybody that way
he had the theory that on the 27th of
May when this cabinet Christ is going on
about whether to accept a offer of peace
mediation from Mussolini not the nicest
guy in Europe that Churchill himself
weakened and wanted to quit and he's
published a book called darkest hour in
which that claim is apparently made
although I haven't read the book and he
asked me about it and I said he said do
you think Churchill had this moment in
May the 27th when he wanted to quit and
I said no and he said why not I said
well you know I I don't know of any it's
hard to prove a negative right but I
don't know of any evidence for it and I
know a lot of evidence that he didn't
what evidence
I said well Churchill wrote stuff down
huge amounts and people around him wrote
stuff down well he claims to see in the
diary of Lord Halifax some basis for
that and so there's a Churchill who's
weary and tired but that point never
gets made and that's because there were
a lot of good people around that movie
not wanting that point made because it
just didn't seem to be true and but it
doesn't bother me too much that even
then on that day that I don't like it
that they showed Churchill drinking all
the time because he did drink all the
time but he was never drunk and it was a
point of pride with him he drank his
first drank in his life when he was a
soldier in India and what they would do
in India and I don't even know if it's
fake news or junk science but they when
they drank water they would pour a
little bit of whiskey in it to think
maybe it would kill the organisms living
in it right and so he developed a taste
for that very weak and he drank that all
day and he did you know deserted about
10 o'clock in the morning if you made
him a strong drink he would pour it in
the fireplace
and now he did drink fair amount of
champagne and wine with lunch and dinner
but I always say you know he was in
politics for fifty five years including
the three two greatest wars in history
and the Great Depression and whilst he
did all that he wrote 50 wonderful books
and about nine thousand closely printed
large pages of speeches all himself if
he was drunk
I'm going to take up the practice
[Laughter]
oh and if you think about that what was
it what was it like on the 27th of May
28th of May
Mussolini's offering pre peace the
French are getting ready to surrender
the French army is broken up didn't
fight very well the British Army is
running to the sea it was just nature
asserting itself the two armies were
joined you know up in northeastern
France in Belgium and both sides of the
Belgian border and the Germans came
around behind in the in 1914 and the
famous sleepin plan they'd swept to the
right well they didn't do it that time
they went through the Ardennes Forest
and mountain tracks and got tanks
through it nobody thought they could do
it and so these two armies are here and
their communication between them and
Paris their communications are
disarranged and cut off and everything
is chaos and the two armies start moving
and you know the people in command only
half know where they are and the French
just by automatic inclination start
moving toward Paris and the British
start moving to the scene there are
marine people see and and they get to
Dunkirk Beach and all that's going on
and the British Army is like 20
divisions something like that maybe
eight divisions I can't remember and the
German army is several hundred and
they're gonna be alone what do they do
and then these people in the cabinet
with Churchill are more popular than
Churchill he hadn't become the greatest
man in the world yet or I argue he
already had just nobody knew it yet but
you know after these days in 1940 after
the year 1944 the rest of his life
everybody he met treated him like he was
the greatest man in the world even
though they might hate him and resist
him but they did it that way now because
Wow you know and and so if you know it
stands to reason he'd be down
and he did write that he would you know
they have this scene in the subway where
these British people and he didn't go
down in the subway and have that but I
loved that scene and I loved it in part
because Churchill says that he would he
writes in the Second World War his
memoir of the 1st of the Second World
War he writes that damn I would drive
along and see people on the street and
then the bus cues and I would see the
resolution on their faces then I would
see the cheer on their faces if they
would cite me he said the island was
suffused in a quite glow
the British were the lion and I was
called upon to give the roar that great
you know I mean that's it and so they
showed those people on the subway giving
him words to say you know one boy says
never write and then the West Indian
British subject right Marcus might have
been his name I think it was and that's
a Roman name right and so Churchill
cites this thing that he memorized when
he was a little boy you wanna hear about
Winston Churchill because Winston
Churchill is very great
yeah when he's a little boy he had it he
was a poor student and a great student
in alteration depending on what he
wanted and so one day they have a
recitation contest and he's reciting at
Harrow school Macaulay's lays of ancient
rome and he starts reciting and he just
keeps going and everybody started
staring around looking and then one of
the dons gets up and goes over to the
shelf and gets the book off and finds
the page and Churchill is still going
and then people look at him and the guy
looks up and he's following it down in
it and he goes you know right tremendous
memory and so one of his very favorite
things out step brave Horatius the
captain of the gate in every life every
man to every man born on this worth
death coming
death cometh soon or late but how can
men die better than facing fearful odds
for the ashes of his father and the
temple of his gods and they have marcus
reciting that with churchill in the
background and that is specifically
Churchill's point churchill believed in
freedom and representative government
among other reasons because he thought
that was braver than these despotisms
and that hard virtue we get a chance to
exercise because we are responsible for
this thing and that means by the way
what Churchill will teach you if you
think that these odds are overwhelming
and they cannot be faced you should get
up in the morning and think that is the
situation for which I was made
[Applause]